help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from timcast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
I want to jump to this story because
this one was uh talk about rhetorical
escalation yes Karine Jean-Pierre
reiterates that tens of millions of
Americans are an extreme threat to our
democracy and freedom their only
supposed crime they vote Republican
again the White House thinks Republicans
are terrorists she actually said that
Maga Republicans yeah uh that's 74
million people who voted for Trump a lot
of people are an extreme threat to our
democracy what do you think she's saying
to the to the country and the world when
she says something like that I think I
know exactly what she's saying I was
talking to Libby about this a little bit
before we started I think the supply
wait what am I trying to say here I
think the demand highly outstrips the
supply of white Nationals terrorism and
they need people
right exactly yeah they need people to
be terrorists so that they can create uh
false terrorism charges well did you say
you can have the Department of Justice
investigate their political opponents
did you see the uh the Vox article
several years ago it was like a hundred
million Americans believe what white
nationalists believe whatever and it was
like some nonsense that had nothing to
do with anything it was like they agree
with you know market capitalism that's
what the other people believe
nationalism Hitler also drank water
meritocracy matters you know
you know that's white nationalists yeah
so is working hard and showing up on but
this is that's all white nationalists
apparently this is the White House
literally coming out and saying to your
face as someone who opposes the
Democrats and the woke cult you are a
threat to their government
typically things like this don't end
well for countries when the official
Administration is coming out and saying
half the people are a threat to us well
that's correct and there's just one the
other thing too is you have a current
Administration investigating the
previous administration right and you
also have current lawmakers who are
Republican lawmakers saying that they
are going to invest if they take the
Congress that they are going to
investigate the current Administration
this is what goes on in you know totally
failed States this is what goes on in
countries that are falling apart is you
know look at Sri Lanka What's Happening
Here Right look at what happened in
Canada right yeah
you see what Trudeau just said yes about
the reason people are angry as climate
change
climate change is one of the reasons
there's so much anger today is that why
you're so angry Chris that's why I'm out
on the street trying to stop the
sterilization of kids it's getting so
warm
1200 million dollars for
two let me see if I can get the whole
thing I can do it for you go for it do
it do it do it so the 2s LGBT a he
forgot the eye
and he only put one plus in there there
should be at least three pluses and then
there should be a WTF yeah honestly
that's fair but he always puts the 2s
first because he's all about virtue
signaling and the 2s stands for two
Spirits right which is apparently it's
not true but it's apparently indigenous
cultures also used to believe that there
were more than two Sexes and you could
be both sexes or none double virtue
signal yeah yeah I love it oh wow yeah a
double virtue yeah it's powerful that's
why it's first but I mean this is a the
climbing the climate change is the
problem they just keep doing it and I'm
just sitting here thinking like do
people really believe this are they
sitting there being like I can't afford
to eat climate change or are they like I
want the government to you know to stop
Banning fuel production and things like
that
the average Canadian
so here's what happens if you don't put
a stop to what's happening in the U.S
because I'm like the canary in the coal
mine we're already way past where you
guys are things are terrible up there we
have three main media sources all on the
government payroll CTV CBC and global
news they would all be bankrupt if not
for government money wow and they just
push Trudeau's agenda and they say
whatever he wants so the average person
has no idea the truth about things
because all they see is this lame stream
media all the time
but
my word we've got the same problems you
guys have the whole world does it's
inflation terrible economy
indoctrination not education
feels like a controlled slow motion
demolition yeah these people believe
that words are violence
and actually they believe that it's
actually
and but that's just because I've never
experienced real hardship like you saw
the thing where Ben Shapiro showed up at
podcast movements yeah you know and his
presence was actual harm that's right I
don't know everyone was stoked to see
him there and they were like can I take
pictures with you I I put up a billboard
about two years ago in Vancouver a real
billboard that said I heart JK Rowling
a Vancouver politician said it was hate
speech what and they took it down the
next day wow love is hate love it had a
heart on it for the world's greatest
children's author
and no sign company in Canada will deal
with me wow this is the state of things
so that's why I had signs made because I
became a billboard and I go out and have
conversations but freedom of speech is
under attack we're lied to constantly
and all the media do is Stoke division
same thing down here you know I recall
that a couple hundred years ago
we hear Americans offered Quebec an
opportunity to revolt against the Quran
and they said no do you guys know that
yeah they would have been the 14th
colony but they were like nah we're not
interested and we were like oh man we
really need their support oh well I
guess not and then we almost took you
guys over do you remember that I think
that might be revisionist history I
think I think we burned down your white
house and your Congress back well no
Britain did yeah yeah it was before
Canada existed right okay fair point we
uh we tried I think we did occupy
Montreal or something like that 65
Canada became a country 1867.
I think we occupied Montreal during the
War of 1812 or something like that oh
nice Montreal is amazing occupying and
it is awesome I mean you're not getting
attacked yeah yeah but imagine this what
if he won
and we took Montreal
y'all be better off
yeah we'd be better off because they
have a really large antifa contingent so
if you want to take over then that's
fine with me yeah you can have them like
take DC yeah but if we did that it would
be a bunch of Maga that I'll be walking
around with American flags and I wonder
yeah I mean I don't think the French
Canadians would be that Maga though no
but who knows who knows man and Montreal
is different within Road not traveled
within the province there's a lot of
English speakers it's very different
compared to the rest of the province I'm
just saying you know
Canada sucks like it's a great place
with great food and great people but I
mean the government and what it's done
to the country has just made it an awful
place this is what happens if AOC was
your president
wow this is exactly what happens Justin
Trudeau president Zoolander is the AOC
equipment up in Canada it talks like
this it's also an example what happens
if you let your government be a puppet
of a king and just pretend like you're
not a puppet of a king like it's can
it's it's British it's it's owned by the
freaking Queen she decides who's in
charge there it's it's that's disgusting
I don't think that's true of the
provincial leadership and they have a
lot of the provincial leaders have a lot
of them I'm pretty sure the Queen of
England technically could intervene but
I don't know if it's political
provincial yeah oh yeah and everything I
don't know if it's realistic though I
don't understand monarchy yeah it's
complicated we have this there's this
person called a governor general who's
actually appointed by the Prime Minister
but is the representative of the queen
you see there it is it's just just a
it's just like a what do you call it
ceremonial sort of thing but is it
though well so here's what can happen
because we don't have
we have we don't have a two-party system
like down here we have four or five
parties that get seats so Justin Trudeau
has a minority of the seats in
government so to pass any law he has to
get some other party to come along with
him so he ends up bribing some other
party by giving them what they want and
that's always an even further left party
but at any time he could be kicked out
if the parties just said no we're not
going to go along with you and then a
new election would get called and it's
the governor general who actually does
that so she does have some role but as
far as I can tell that's about it I
think we just look to Canada and if we
do not win the culture War that's what's
in store for us so we're lucky in that
regard that we get to watch it happen to
you guys and then be like hey we we
don't want that to happen here so let's
uh you know Shore up our defenses get
out and vote get out and vote in
November there was a time in American
history where there was a rebellion a
violent Rebellion people were shot
people it was called Shay's Rebellion it
was in 17. oh yeah
1783 is right around right after the
Revolution and um a bunch of farmers
were being taxed with for money they
didn't have so they rioted they went to
the courthouses over the course of like
a week or multiple days and weeks or
whatever and uh violently surrounded
them the judges were like I'm out of
here I'm not adjudicating we're not
going to steal their land the governor
cracked down hard like he wanted
people's executed he wanted people
arrested and it was he was calling
people I don't know if he was using the
word terrorists but calling you know the
whole Insurgency thing we got to go
after people the farmers are our enemies
and they were like if you start killing
Americans because they are revolting
because they can't pay their taxes
that's a bad road to go down it's a very
bad road to go down eventually John
Hancock came back in and won the
governorship and pardoned everybody
except for two guys who were looters and
they got executed but it was the pardon
that it was like the road to Banana
republicanism we saw it we saw it where
it was just just another cycle of the
week becoming strong executing the weak
and trying to hold strength and that and
they they they said a situation where we
have a president who told us that taxes
were not going to be raised on people
making under 400 000 it's very that's a
trick like they are they are being
raised and they have employed all of
these IRS agents
raising taxes that's the trick the trick
is they say we're not going to raise
your taxes no we're going to just bill
you on your existing taxes and claim you
owe us right yeah yeah but they're also
I mean they're going after the middle
class again yeah of course yeah the
villainization of an entire group of
people like what they said about Mega
Republicans is like this boat what
bodoin did in Massachusetts and the mega
Republicans are like these are middle
class small business owners you know
nail shop owners out in the middle of
Indiana or wherever and they're going to
end up paying a whole bunch more get
more pissed and then be called
terrorists very much like history might
repeat itself here because in
Massachusetts for Shea's Rebellion that
the governor was out of it was Hancock
was governor and saw the Rebellion on
the horizon was like I'm I'm resigning I
can't do this anymore so he left then
this new governor came in became this
Tyrant kind of like what Biden's doing
claiming people are terrorists I don't
like it and then eventually Hancock was
like okay I can't not do anything he's
he ran again got back into the
governorship and pardoned people now if
we have a president it runs again and
then comes back into the presidency and
pardons people wouldn't that be an
interesting well you know revolution of
the past you know right that was funny
that if Donald Trump is indicted and
goes to prison or is in jail or whatever
and then is still running for president
and wins he can pardon himself
oh is that right can you pardon me
yourself I I think it's debatable yeah I
remember there was a lot of talk about
this a few years ago it would get
challenged but apparently he could I
think I mean what do you do when someone
in prison is elected president
just safe there you know what I mean I
guess
sort of safe depending on what kind of
prison he's in well and I guess the
charges would be things like obstruction
of justice mishandling of documents that
are in your possession that you actually
own that's what they're trying to go can
you run for president if you're in
prison no you can't well hold on they're
going they're going after this records
law that says if you obfuscate
manipulate or destroy records you can't
run for office that's what they're
trying to do they just really don't want
them to run again everything that
they've been doing is about that's the
same thing with Shay's Rebellion they
wanted to strip these people of all
their voter rights they wanted to strip
people of their land they took They
seized people's property like they're
trying to make them non-cities they were
trying to make them non-citizens and
eventually it was just like you can't do
that you can't you can't make a country
if you're making people nonsense that's
correct yeah thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there